welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is David Simon a lecture of political
science and ethics politics and
economics at Yale University David Simon
studies African politics focusing on the
politics of development assistance and
post-conflict situations particularly in
Rwanda he is editor of the historical
dictionary of Zambia and has contributed
to comparative political studies the
Journal of Commonwealth and comparative
politics and the Journal of genocide
research he also teaches classes on
international relations in Africa and
the comparative politics of development
today we talked with professor Simon
about building state capacity to prevent
atrocity crimes welcome professor Simon
thank you for inviting me it's a
pleasure to be here ok we are almost at
the 20th anniversary of genocide in
Rwanda 2014 being the year for the 20th
anniversary how has that country
recovered to what extent hasn't
recovered at this point 20 years later
Rwanda is recovery has really been
remarkable if you consider the scale of
what happened there hundreds of
thousands of people killed no one knows
the precise numbers the the country of
seven million in the first place
millions of refugees and displaced
persons and destruction throughout the
countryside twenty years later the
country is in many ways one of Africa
success stories in what way the economy
is growing in the upper single digits
and sometimes in double digits per year
the the country it has embarked on
ambitious plans to start new industries
engage in new economic activities the
place is
of the cleanest countries in Africa
there's been a had a Rwandan friend here
last week and he could just shake us all
he could do was shake his head at the
litter of plastic bags in our countries
because plastic bags for example are
banned in Rwanda rwanda has climbed up
in a good sense the the anti-corruption
rankings transparency international
rankings and an unprecedented rise from
the 150 160 range out of the 200 or so
or 185 countries that transparency
international ranks to the 60s and 70s
one of the least corrupt countries in
Africa all of that is absolutely
remarkable and that's primarily on the
economic and governance side the more
difficult question and the question I
think that's harder to answer is how it
has recovered on the social and
political sides socially the there is a
level of peace that is highly
commendable as I said it's one of the
safest countries and it's not just crime
it's that there's very little chance of
political violence in that country again
something remarkable given the scale of
destruction and violence in 1994 however
all of this both the economic and the
social peace has come it's at I don't
know if it's a cost or has has been made
possible by a fairly firm a less a firm
political hand a less than competitive
democracy and anytime you're in that
situation I think history shown it's
hard to gauge just how much dissent and
discontent there is until it it boils
over and there are many people who
believe that that Rwanda is has sort of
shoved a lot of its troubles under the
carpet with it but we'll have to
confront them at some point what kind of
problems ethnic
just content for one so so that still
exists basically well it's interesting
that the crux of the genocide in Rwanda
was that there had been a civil war an
invasion by a predominantly Tutsi army
and the tootsies comprised about fifteen
percent of the population Hutus
comprised most of the rest as tiny
sliver belong to the betwa ethnic group
and the Hutus were in power back in 1994
what happened was in response to this
rebel invasion the Hutu government
actually after a piece of peace peace
accord in 1993 the government was trying
to establish a transitional government a
power-sharing government and the
extremists on the government side
supporters of the government who didn't
want to see that power-sharing
arrangement take place undermined all
efforts to cede it and including
assassinating the president of who to
who had who had agreed on this
power-sharing arrangement or at least
that's the for me the most convincing
theory as to what triggered the genocide
but then the Hutu civilian Hutus police
militias supporting the government or
the extremists within the government
essentially said about massacring the
entire Tutsi population as best they
could over the course of 100 days so the
essence of the genocide is ethnic
violence between Hutus and tootsies in
fact in rwanda it's called the genocide
of the tootsies just to make clear who
was perpetrator and who was victim in
the Tutsi government's eyes so the the
current government has socially mandated
that people not refer to themselves as
Hutu or Tutsi s and almost any Rwandan
you meet will say something along the
lines of there are no such thing as
Hutus and tootsies anymore we are all
Rwandan but can you tell physically the
difference is there
way to tell not really there are
certainly stereotypes that hold true
someone's a stereotypical looking to tea
or a stereotypical looking who to
chances are even they have mixed blood
so to speak but by and large most people
look you know many more people defy
these stereotypes than actually realize
them as anyone tracking how the Tutsi
population has come back well there has
it come back come back in 20 years I
mean that's rad a relatively short time
period right it hasn't come back
naturally in the sense of the the
remnants of the Rwandan population
regenerating through marriage and and
and births however the Tutsi population
is larger now than it was in 1994
largely because of what's called the
retro a population the this Tutsi rebel
army was comprised of of exiles and the
families of exiles who had left the
country back around the time of
independence in the early 1960s had had
lived in what was then a year and in
Uganda and numbered by 1990 when this
rebellion started in the hundreds of
thousands as the Tutsi as this Tutsi
rebel army who who abandoned the
ceasefire once it was clear a genocide
was starting to take place when it was
clear civilian Rwanda Tutsi civilians
were being targeted this really
foreign-based rebel army base in rebel
foreign tootsies relaunched their their
their insurgency toppled the government
after about three months and has been in
power ever since as they established
their control and power in middle of
1994 hundreds of thousands of these
former exiles and families of
descendents if those exiles moved back
into the country so that right now
although you're not one ought not to
speak of Tootsie's in Rwanda at least in
the government's I
there are both a survivor as a survivor
Tutsi population and their progeny and a
retro a Tutsi population the latter
probably is greater than the former
however one of the things that's sort of
missing is a if there's been a census it
has avoided for sort of understandable
reasons ethnic nomenclature and and so
no one really knows what the population
of which group is particularly since its
government policy not to to recognize
those groups in the present I'll go
there is recognition of those groups as
part of history anyone ok so now 20
years later what can we take away from
that experience and with the hopes of
preventing it from happening again think
that that's a great question i think
there are really two dimensions of it
one is to look at what happened in
Rwanda to look at what Rwandan did or
not did or did not do and the other is
to look at the international community's
reaction I think in some ways what
really makes the the 20th anniversary of
Rwanda a point of retrospection is that
many of the same issues about
international responses to mass
atrocities are I think obviously on our
table staring us in the face once again
it's not only that it's it's not only
the sort of timeliness of it for that
reason but it rwanda matters because in
a way it's the Rwanda is the sort of
crucible for a somewhat undetermined set
of responses that we have in front of us
rwanda has shaped the notion of of how
we respond and how we ought to respond
to mass atrocities without providing a
high earn clad answer and so what
happened in Rwanda and it's also
important to note that at April 1994
or was the exact same time that the
first of the so-called un safe areas in
Bosnia and garage de was being overrun
by Serbian militias so in two instances
in the world you had civilian
populations being threatened by
insurgencies or militias violent actors
and you had the United Nations with a
presence in both cases there was a
United Nations force in Rwanda in 1994
but in both cases the UN completely
backed down allowed civilian populations
essentially to be slaughtered and so the
first the first turn after 1994 after
both of those episodes and for Bosnia
really took the fall of Sherbourne Itza
and the onslaught against zeppa in in
1995 but following those were traumatic
experiences for the international
community and particularly for UN
peacekeepers for whom this happened on
their watch and so in both cases you had
this sort of this phase of introspection
of report writing that culminated in a
resolve to do better it could have
resulted in and there are many people
who argued that that Bosnia and Rwanda
proved that the UN should not get
involved in these situations that they
were out of control that there was
nothing that they that the UN could do
and that therefore they should just
retreat however what carried the day was
the realization that there were actors
on the ground that could have made a
difference but did not and in fact in
Rwanda what happened was there was this
two thousand strong peacekeeping force
2,500 in fact strong peacekeepers on the
ground in Rwanda two weeks after the
start of the genocide had not
necessarily been recognized as a
genocide yet but on April 21st 1994 the
UN voted to withdrawal almost the entire
force why because the Li
being members of the Security Council
the most involved members of the
Security Council I did not want to put
their troops in harm's way and they
maybe they didn't have as good a read of
the situation as they would have liked
in fact they were getting we know now
from looking back at the at the record
they were getting conflicting reports
from two different actors on the ground
both whom both of whom represented the
UN General romeo Dallaire was the force
commander for you Namir the UN
peacekeeping force and he was saying we
need more troops we need we can stop
this que haces is breaking out but
there's a lot that we can do and
meanwhile the the secretary-general
special representative of a political
figure rather than a military figure was
saying chaos is breaking out but all we
what we have to bring the political
leaders together we have to negotiate
with these with these two forces that
are fighting one another we need a
ceasefire and if there's not going to be
a ceasefire there's no room for for un
intervention but price so that that sort
of mixed message situation gave I think
the Security Council cover to withdraw
but in fact the the instructions from
Washington from Paris from London became
get those guys out it recalled this is
six months after the tragedy in
Mogadishu the Black Hawk Down incident
in which was it 19 u.s. Rangers were
Army Rangers were killed in what seemed
like a very similar action an
intervention I therrien intervention
that was designed originally designed to
protect civilian lives and so the US had
no appetite Clinton had no appetite for
ramping up intervention in another
admittedly obscure African I was going
to get to that point it's because
probably it was in Africa
necessarily I think that that not more
was done right and many people looking
back said their first reaction was
Rwanda I'd better figure out where that
is on a map they just had heard of it
before okay so now as you know we look
at Darfur today and more recently Syria
how can we take what we learned in
Rwanda and apply it to those places okay
great the the as I was saying after
nineteen ninety around 1999 you had the
spirit this period of introspection and
retrospection Kofi Annan who was the
director of peacekeeping operations at
the time at the time of Rwanda and
therefore I think felt as Clinton did
sort of guilty and complicit in some
ways commissioned actually probably has
an African yes yes a non-commissioned a
group a private group of individuals
called the international commission on
intervention and state sovereignty or
Isis that he asked to make
recommendations regarding what should we
do when these mass atrocities start to
unfold what should the United Nations do
and they came up with what is this
commission so agitated for several
months and came back with the proposal
for the doctrine of responsibility to
protect which says that there are that
first of all states have a
responsibility to protect their own
populations and proposes that the
international community help States do
that but also says that when states fail
to protect their own populations the
international community has a
responsibility to step in and provide
that protection so we have this sort of
doctrinal response available to us
something we can sort of hang our code
on as we as we say we're going in and
doing this however the existence of
doctrine doesn't necessarily guide us
very well in a new situation serious now
Rwanda dar fur is not Rwanda nor does it
Bosnia nor are
either one of these Kosovo which is sort
of the third instance that inspired a
new new doctrine one of the core
proposals of Isis of responsibility to
protect is that if there is to be
international intervention it be
international and character and in fact
that the UN along with regional
organizations are recognized to have the
sort of legitimacy that bilateral actors
in bilateral actors don't bilateral
actors may have the ability the will to
intervene but ultimately that
intervention becomes the edge it emit in
international terms if it it sort of
contravenes what the Security Council
has said of course the Security
Council's very political body you've
seen divisions especially between Russia
and China on one side the US and
sometimes France and sometimes UK on the
other not you know having fundamental
disagreements on whether or not the
sovereign responsibilities of a
government like Syria have been
abrogated in okay so you've recently
written a paper about building state
capacity to prevent atrocity crimes and
implementing their responsibility to
protect framework so what are the basic
tenants of that responsibility to
protect doctrine two points to start out
with one is that the responsibility to
protect does in fact involve a much
broader sort of menu or set of ideas
than bombing a place when sending in
bombers when atrocities are unfolding
and in fact the impetus for writing this
this paper was essentially a policy
brief was to to try to highlight many of
the upstream action
that can be done to prevent atrocities
from happening in the first place like
what and so there are a couple different
different sets of actions one are the
the types of things that you can do to
make a state stronger in a way that it
that it can prevent mass atrocities part
of that is if we if we're figuring that
mass atrocities happen because non-state
actors undertake them and this is part
of the it's not a fiction because those
do happen but it's a fiction that that's
the only way in which it happens but it
helped sell this doctrine to the United
Nations membership to say that we are
trying to strengthen States to prevent
to to prevent or to allow them to
prevent others from from committing mass
atrocities but there are things that can
be done a stronger and this is important
more professional police force that is
trained in respecting human rights and
acting against those who would deny
others human rights a legal framework
that provides for that institutions that
allow civilians to register complaints
we don't have these in the United States
we don't have a human rights commission
or an ombudsman because we think our
political process can handle that handle
and a little that better but those are
the types of institutions that I think
can be made fairly robust and are
promising as a sort of stand-ins for
maybe for the political process the the
other thing though that I was going to
say about this is that the way that
states can prevent mass atrocities is
not to commit them in the first place
and in fact if we look at the past
decade or so of mass atrocities states
are if not complicit
or if not doing themselves doing them
themselves I have been complicit in
those those mass atrocities so the
second cut at this is well what can a
how can a state sort of constrain itself
or better yet how can a civilian
population strengthen itself to stand up
to a state without engaging in conflict
which is more likely to result in a
situation where mass atrocities happen I
mean looking at Syria Syria started at
as Arab spring-style protest Tunisian
style protests devolved into sort of
pitched battles between the government
and protesters and ultimately to
outright civil war with weapons of
massive mass destruction being used so
the two components of constraining a
state are one a legal framework and it's
interesting to see this come up just in
the past few days where Syria has
expressed willingness to sign the
Convention against chemical weapons
which it had not signed before these
international instruments really do
matter they provide enforcement
mechanisms they provide protocols for in
the case of chemical weapons for
disposing of certain materials there are
there are trade arrangements that go
along with that and the when a a country
a seeds to a protocol or a convention or
ratify the Convention like this the
international community has more
purchase on that country when it looks
like it might be about to violate when
its state might be about to violate
those conventions so that these things
really matter and there are a wide range
of conventions regarding human rights
regarding the rights of minorities
chemical weapons etc that that can
constrain the state the second realm is
as I proposed before what civil society
can do
and in particular peaceful civil society
because sometimes arguably civil society
creates militias the the Serbian
militias that were some of the most
violent back in the the Bosnian Wars
actually arose out of a football club a
soccer team support group so civil
society is not always good and happy
times however in its ideal form if it
has the space if people have the space
to act together without being monitored
or controlled or subject to government
reprisal simply for getting together
then I think there is a greater chance
of of resisting sort of extremism in the
government and it matters actually
because governments are seldom a
monolithic in these points of crisis
you'll have would be moderates and would
be extremists and if the would be
moderate snow that they have support in
civil society they have more of a
possibility of prevailing in that intro
government struggle for power and I
think we've seen that in various cases
perhaps in a place like Tunisia perhaps
even to some extent in post-gaddafi
Libya where there are extremists out
there and there are what I'm calling
very stylized sense of moderates and you
know sometimes the moderates win and
that happens in particular when both
within this within the government and
within civil society they're enabled or
empowered if I could bring one more
example of what civil society can do
it's very inspiring example in 2003 I
believe Liberia was at the what turned
out to be the very tail end of 12 years
of turmoil not constant civil war but
two or three iterations
armed violence between government and
and militia groups and peace talks
seemed to be about to fail at that at
that juncture and it looked like you
know for all the best efforts for the US
it sent a battleship of some sort and a
marine contingent that it actually
landed in the outskirts of Monrovia and
then sort of mysteriously to the
librarian population retreated they were
just doing some reconnaissance it turns
out but a group of Liberian women who
had sort of become empowered through
this civil society movement and had
fancied themselves as a political force
to be reckoned with decided that they
were going to stand up to these
negotiators these militia negotiators
military negotiators who were kind of
giving up and they said they surrounded
the the form of negotiations and said
you know we're not leaving you're going
to have to walk through us you're going
to have to trample us it'll look
horrible internationally go back in and
and make peace and in fact the
culmination of that was Charles Taylor's
agreement he was then the the the
president but sort of he had no
international credibility so the his
agreement to go into exile in Nigeria
where after a few years he was corralled
and his and sent to the Hague so it's a
long story with many twists but it's
there's this inspiring moment at which
civil society stood up to prevent
further hostilities if not specifically
mass atrocities it's very inspiring but
unfortunately I think very unusual and
and what strikes me is 20 years later
that we're still dealing with countries
in different ways instead of some
uniform where to take care of you know
mass killings right there are a couple
reasons for the
one is that as I said before no no mass
atrocity situation is like the previous
one just as our mesa ven millions of
people being the millions millions of
people be guild or sometimes even just
thousands or tens of thousands of people
being killed it can still mass atrocity
the mass part need not reach a certain
threshold what is actually the minimum
there really is no minimum according to
the Genocide Convention there don't even
there do not there does not have to be a
minimum death toll simply the
contemplation of the elimination of a
protected group is enough for there to
be for the Genocide Convention to come
into effect practically numbers matter a
shooting of five protesters of a certain
ethnic group with someone saying you
know death to all of them which would
you know signal the intent to destroy in
part which is all the UN you know
practically I said strictly speaking
that might constitute an act of genocide
practically no one's going to pull the
imaginary genocide convention fire alarm
and say now we have to act however mass
atrocities and mass atrocities is a
broader category that includes genocide
but also includes the war crimes the use
of weapons of mass destruction for
example you know a thousand can be can
be enough right but sometimes the
numbers can be a distraction I think and
things like the intent the the horror
the vulnerability of civilian
populations the extent to which a
specific group is threatened those items
may matter more but to get back to your
question about why don't we have a a
sort of standard response the situations
are different and the tendency is to is
to fight the last mass atrocity or to
counter the last mass atrocity and often
that what was right last time
isn't right this time in although there
was a civil war in Rwanda or in Darfur
for that matter the relative power and
capability of the rebels in Darfur or
Syria is a lot different in the
composition of those rebels and the sort
of legitimacy and a willingness to work
with those rebels is a lot different now
than it was or would have been in Rwanda
because of course in Rwanda we didn't
work with those rebels in the end we let
the rebels win and that was the solution
to the to the genocide the the meaning
that the rebels the RPF the Tutsi rebel
group stop the genocide but the second
reason is that you know the situation on
the ground is different each time the
second reason is that the situation in
New York or Geneva is different the
International constellation is different
so in retrospect in Rwanda maybe there
could have been if the Security Council
fought a little harder thought about it
a little longer there could have been
more resolute action in fact three weeks
after the sort of shameful withdrawal of
UN peacekeepers they reversed course and
authorized a 5,000 peacekeeper force to
to go to or wanted to stop the genocide
and it arrived two weeks after the
genocide was over but there was you know
concerted action in Libya there was or
with respect to Libya there was a some
unanimity at this that we were able to
get a Security Council resolution passed
and and NATO was given sort of the
responsibility to use the force
necessary to end atrocities and the
record what the force necessary was and
what the strategy necessary was did that
include regime change but there was
there was enough of a consensus
is within the Security Council to
authorize something in Syria we don't
see that at all okay and so ask you what
do you think is going to happen there in
Syria I don't know it's it's uncharted
territory in the sense that on one hand
we have this doctrine of responsibility
to protect on the other hand we have
more reluctance by more parties to put
it into place and on the ground it's a
very very messy situation the ultimately
the idea of the doctrine rests on the
protection of civilians not on helping
one side or the other wind and the more
we see this the more I think see this
conflict unfold the uglier it's getting
the the less we we don't want to help
one side or the other wind but going in
and finding setting up zones of
protection which was the 1990 failed
1990s method in Bosnia at least seems
well off the radar at this point taking
military action against one side or the
other is obviously it's been
contemplated but even as it was
contemplated as an appropriate response
as a new sort of scale wise because
there has to be response to alleged and
fairly obvious war crimes just the
effectiveness of them has been was
called into question by military
observers and military analysts and
political analysts as well and people
were saying well you know is a is a
symbolic strike that doesn't change
anything militarily is that what
responsibility to protect calls for and
many of the most ardent supporters of
responsibility to protect say no they
say you need the legitimacy of the UN
that we talked about before hand and you
need a chance of effectiveness to some
extent the the Russian proposal that's
on the table now 22 get the Assad
government to give up its chemical
weapons is is a godsend because it's not
causing it's not prompting this real
crisis in responsibility to protect on
the other hand you could say going back
to our earlier part of our discussion
it's exactly the type of thing that
responsibility protect also involves and
that is looking in the toolbox and
seeing what else is there employing
international standards applying
international standards sending
inspectors in at some point it's going
to be very difficult to time before but
that principle in a way reflects I think
a victory for the notion of
responsibility to protect in a broader
sense and a reminder that we have to
view that doctrine in a broader sense
and not just a a doctrine of when do we
intervene and and with how much force
because it doesn't those two questions
are ultimately political questions that
the UN Security Council and or regional
equivalence have to decide and and are
much more difficult therefore to come
with perhaps the answer that that
citizens and and observers of the sort
of atrocity prevention community what we
would ultimately want okay thank you so
much for being here with us today and
sharing your work thank you very much
it's been a pleasure for more
information about professor Simon and
his research please visit our website at
yale edu slash macmillan report be sure
to join us again for another episode of
the macmillan report made possible
through funding from the Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Center for International
and area studies at Yale